bonjour tout le monde alors on se
retrouve pour suivre les aventures de la
bourdonnais est donc dans ce match
contre mcdonnell
après la première victoire qu'on a vu
dans la vidéo précédente mcdonald's
s'est rebiffé allait aligner deux
victoires de suite et donc eh ben on en
est là il ya deux impôts mcdonell qui a
les blancs alors c'est parti
eux quatre ces cinq dons de l'abandonner
waimes bienvenue des sicilienne et on y
reviendra plus tard mais il jouait des
cantons ouvrait 6ème ce qui n'est pas
toujours le cas donc quand je vois aussi
en série à trois des quatre il aimait
beaucoup je veux qu'à lycées 6 des
quatre prises prises et e5 donc ce qu'on
appelle aussi la kalachnikov
donc je connais bien parce que j'avais
écrit un livre avec m car note là dessus
mais voilà un peu le père fondateur
c'était c'était de la bourdonnais qu on
y reviendra plus tard ce qui lève une
belle partie là dessus qu'on mcdonnell
mais le coup préféré de magasins à
l'époque c'était de jouer f4 pour
prendre prendre le centre ma foi
pourquoi pas c'est pas mauvais coup même
si on enfile au fil du temps on préfère
clairement je veux qu'il y ait 3 et les
4 ou au moins du du fou les cinq des
coups comme ça mais mais voilà ce coup
sur coup au f4 pas mauvais donc on s'est
peut-être maintenant c'est pas mal de
rachat avec des 5
mais ce que je joue de la bordeaux n'est
pas mauvais c'est aussi ce qu'avait les
f3 keolis et 6 les blancs font ces trois
d'entre vous le créez un énorme centre
et d5 une création central des noirs et
à près de 5 sa ressemble beaucoup à une
française et c'est le genre de position
qu'on peut rencontrer dans la française
après eux quatre six f4 en fait sur ce
genre de choses on pourrait avoir
quasiment même exactement la même
position puisque les blancs pourrait
très bien choisir de ces trois-là créé
le gros centre etc et et pour tout dire
très bien enfin j'aime beaucoup comme
l'abandonner à traiter la position alors
il a fait office directes contre attaque
le centre des blancs et là-dessus
mcdonnell se développer avec food
ok pourquoi pas à noter qu'ici la
plupart du temps mcdonald's aimait bien
joué le coup cavaliers à 3 et d'ailleurs
c'est un truc assez marrant parce que en
moi avec les normes de l'ue car j'ai eu
exactement cette position je veux à
l'open de reykjavik et mon adversaire
qui était un sud-américain les jeux
comme ça j'avais jocaille h6 effet kelly
c2 et j'avais échangé ici avec fawcett
des quatre je crois j'ai vu calibre 5 et
buffle ou deux petits rats rock outils à
bref mais j'avais suivi pendant quelques
coups en fait les coûts de l'avoir donna
je ne sais pas si j'étais d'ailleurs
courant que shiva cette partie-là mai
mais voilà donc donc marrant de voir que
je sais pas plus de 150 ans plus tard
c'est en 180 ans plus tard nous on suit
les mêmes coûts alors dans cette partie
il faut deux joué par par mcdonald's est
bien ici développé fawcett très bien
cavaliers à 3 donc on voit très sont en
tout cas les va revenir vers ses 2 sera
menée vers le centre et aussi aider à
jouer des 4es à bien sécuriser ses
options puisque les noirs ou pour
pouvoir mettre la pression dessus avec
d'investissement aussi que ce cavalier
qui peut venir sûr archi 7 5
ça ferait le cavaliere f5 lecavalier en
c6 la dame en v6 et le pion ici qui
montrait pression donc assez logique je
dois par des blancs de faire tout ça
voilà on fout des trois avant ça je ne
sais pas c'est un peu un peu mollasson
j'ai envie de dire quand même de
retoucher se fout et de le bouger deux
fois dans l'ouverture il y avait mieux à
faire
par exemple petit rock sûrement quelque
chose comme ça mais bon il faut des
trois cavaliers b4 jouer prise prises et
les blancs choisy-le-roi f2 alors ça
peut paraître surprenant de se laisser
des rockets aussi facilement
mais son idée c'était d'arriver à faire
un rock à la main et en aurait fait un
projet à plus tard donc pourquoi pas et
non en rock et en tout cas tu aurais fin
si on prend 1,5
si on prend 1,5 et la étrange parce que
la borne au maire à tinqueux plaignent
pas trop dur c'est dire que dalle 3d 4
quand même ça se voit quoi cette option
n'est pas défendu le cavalier lecavalier
cloud et donc d'un premier 4 aussi
important on fait chaque si elles payent
chaque blessure est grave pour acheter
la dame sera prise mais comme on fait
chaque fois sans la menace prime donc
les blancs des rouges et noirs ont
soustrait la dame la casse des quatre
ans la main j 4 par exemple on attaque
g2 est quand même là les blancs sont
assez mal ils ont perdu un pion central
qui plus est le roi ici a super bien
placé
quel est l'avenir sur f5 on a les tours
qu'ils sont sur l'école nous verse
celle-là ensuite déjà l'autre ensuite
arrive et puis établi qu'à id4car evra
et ouais ça se passe pas très bien donc
étonnant en fait un qui n'a loupé ça
mais bon quel et f5 prise prises et
finalement il se cache en rien mais
quand même domination des noirs pour
l'instant parce que on à la paire de fou
on a toujours des quatre en point de
mire
et comme dit les tours quand même bien
placé sur les colonnes ouverte
alors là les gens n'y a fait j'ai quatre
pareil cas d'affaiblissement vers le roi
c'est pas super conseil a conseillé tout
rêve ça est à 4 il double les toits
blancs de la colonne f fou ou trois fous
le sais tu pourquoi pas on retire le fou
maintenant la dame s'ouvre à la taille
de mes 2 il ya eu dames 2 et les dames
b3 novak les blancs mais c'est quand
même beaucoup de trous dans la position
park la dame là eh bien elle attaque b2
jette un oeil sur ce fou et en attaque
aussi le pion à 4 donc ça fait beaucoup
de choses bougent et sain qui a été joué
il refuse les changes des fous pourquoi
pas et il est fin et croisée 2 et là par
contre belle petite combinaison de la
part de la part des noirs donc étonnant
évidemment de faire cette maison-là
d'avoir raté le simple dames des quatre
tout à l'heure mais c'est comme ça donc
tout reprend avec 3 bravo tout reprend
tout reprendra me prend enfin il n'a pas
fait dans le prend mais d'un ne prend
que s'ils voulaient faire dame trembler
2 puisqu'il y avait un échec et la tour
un très net donc ça va gagner une pièce
est derrière ça gagne des gènes pièce
avec les blancs il a juste fait donc
toursel ici il s'en est allé mais
maintenant la partie est décidé et
puisqu'on a déjà une pièce de plus et
est donc ici en plus on va faire tous
les pions et là donc il a abandonné avec
les blancs mais ba bonne partie bien
construite de la part de la cour donne
avec les noirs j'ai bien aimé en tant
que langue française surtout voir voilà
c'était très construit très cohérent
comme jeu et voilà donc le match bien
lancée égalisation à 2-2 et on verra
donc la suite dans les prochaines vidéos
à plus tard